[Music]
in a universe full of characters past
their Prime gone for good or just no the
MCU will beautifully and respectfully
more the loss of a real-life hero
between setting up ironheart on Disney
plus Thunderbolts in theaters next year
black panther 3 coming soon and screw it
why not black panther 4 son of black
panther you can't be sure of anything in
this life except for death and Disney
sequels
wakanda forever
return to wakanda or at least that one
Street in wakanda where everything
happens
in the wake of black panther one
t'challa opened up his country to the
outside world but mobs put an end to
that foolishness real quick
now this insular nation is under attack
from the talocon in a film that pits
black and brown people against each
other while the CIA takes the week off
because someone else is doing their jobs
for them your olive oil is about to go
bad
watch Leticia Wright overcome onset
injury and online clownery to shine as
the New Black Panther eventually
before she earns her claws sure he has
to deal with all of wakanda's problems
herself the High Council is giving her
major lip his only crime was
intimidation she doesn't fit in at
school at her balls keep turning red
she'll lead her people to Victory by
doing every important job in the country
till she resorts to
performance-enhancing drugs and learns
her lesson the hard way natural purple
herb from the Earth all good synthetic
purple drank from the lab you're gonna
have a bad time
at least mix it with Sprite in a Jolly
Rancher Journey to the only place more
moisturized than wakanda the literal
ocean the talocani are just as advanced
as the service world complete with
tactical water balloons
and even without Macklemore have songs
that make you want to drown yourself
meet their powerful leader Namor
tenacuerto fills out the role so well
they had to shrink his cajones imposed
his only weaknesses are wakandan ashy
technology if we could find a way to dry
his out he won't be as strong and
overworked Marvel affects teams
this Noble Warrior is fighting to
protect his people from Invasion but
since he's also the bad guy in a Marvel
movie his methods take things too far so
we can all cheer while the hero's pound
is out of the sand say it with me
Avengers status quo status quo status
quo status quo and that's not all folks
when you act now and watch wakanda
forever Marvel will throw in 45 minutes
of Phase 5 play setting at no extra
charge like human McGuffin Riri Williams
she's here purely to get chased around
and imprisoned by other characters you
can come to wakanda conscious or
unconscious in a thankless role that
would remind you of America Chavez if
America Chavez had any character
development to remember she made portals
or something and liked pizza balls this
marvelous Miss reary is super quippy so
y'all stop having black panthers when I
get kidnapped loves attention there's an
entire YouTube channel dedicated to
Simon Zumi and gives a lot of helmet cam
so you'd think she's being set up to be
the next iron
but sure he's the one making armor
losing parents drafting teenagers into
war and having an AI do all the work so
I guess she took the Iron Man job too
riri's not even the best Riri in their
Universe
you look good suit up with returning
favorites like Okoye in a thrilling
episode of Wacky Races
Nakia who goes undercover as Nakia with
glasses Queen ramonda who gives an
oscar-worthy performance mourning her
son because practice makes perfect this
is
mbaku protector of wakanda's green
screen District
[Music]
aneka and the biggest waste of Michaela
Cole since last Jedi's unidentified
tactical officer Everett Ross whose
ex-wife finds out about the beads he's
been hiding up his butt all those years
what about the beads
and valdefontaine still a half-baked
character no one cares about after three
MCU appearances you know it's a really
long movie but you can take a pee break
whenever they try to make Val happen
it's not gonna happen I'm gonna go to
the bathroom so if you only see one
sequel full of beautiful underwater
photography about the evils of
colonialism from an indigenous
perspective fighting for control of a
natural resource that enhances human
potential said among a blue-skinned race
who's friends with whales that
introduces the children of the heroes
from the first film and brings back some
legendary dead Warriors then dang you've
got a tough choice in your hands I guess
it depends on how much cry face you want
to look at
[Music]
foreign
oh dang it
starring
Princess Leia knocked up waiting to
impale my man they hate us for our free
men Julia Louis Typecast Bach in action
we have Robert Downey Jr at home what
movies think a college dorm room looks
like blue meanie ah Nemours female
counterpart named Maura very clever
Marvel Comics writers you did it again
and the incredible restraint to not
defect Chadwick Boseman here truly the
first time Disney's Let the dead rest in
peace
cadwoman versus Aquaman
I think that one day artificial
intelligence is going to kill us all my
AI isn't like the movie's mother sure
the threat of AI is like the movies to
the audience but to you it should be way
more real
are you watching the last of us while we
try to think of anything bad or funny to
say about it click here to watch the
weekly after show over on Gamespot
Universe you'll eat less than you desire
and more than you deserve my voice is
bacon for your ears if the apocalypse
comes beat me